sponsored by step finance your go to d5
portfolio manager on solana bitmex the
og crypto derivatives platform and the
best place to buy your bitcoin
hey guys anna welcome back to another
episode of the leia heil pen show so
this show as you should know by now is
sponsored by the cryptocurrency exchange
bitmex so as of may the 17th so it's
been now they're launching a brand new
spot exchange to easily and instantly
buy and sell crypto so to celebrate the
launch of this sport exchange they are
giving away one million dollars in
crypto to spot traders over the next few
months and this is one of the biggest
giveaways i've personally seen in crypto
so if you do want to enter i'm going to
leave the link for you and more
information about that in the
description below that's on youtube um
it's gonna be really exciting there's a
huge range of different assets that you
can um have access to so i just want to
say a massive shout out and a big thank
you to bitmex because without them we
wouldn't be able to bring you such
interesting conversations conversations
which we're sort of not really allowed
to have these days um so i'm happy that
bimx are basically helping us get the
word out there um about all the rubbish
that is going on in the world right now
so if you are watching on youtube please
don't forget to hit the subscribe button
because we're always gonna bring you top
quality guests and we're going to be
talking about some of the craziest
things in the world right now um which
really is you know the clamping down on
freedom of speech so joining me today is
kenny florian a former ufc competitor
and carla commentator for pfl and a
battle bot let's bring it kenny in kenny
welcome to the show how are you
i'm well thanks thanks for having me
yeah it's my pleasure i'm super excited
to chat with you um you are i think the
third fighter i've had on the show um
what's going on why are all you fighters
interested in crypto um i think you're
more specifically interested in bitcoin
but we'll get to that um but why are you
into crypto what's the connection here
yeah you know
it's a good question i guess i'll speak
for myself here um
yeah i got in the space i guess in like
2017
um got into you know crypto in general
uh and then eventually you know just
moved into bitcoin i think about a year
year and a half later
um so i
i think for me
i like the idea uh first of all of
you know
doing things that are a little bit
differently uh they're a little bit
different from what other people are
doing um
and uh
i i think that um i guess i'm a little
bit more open-minded to things and
um i also think i i have i put a
tremendous
value on my time um
as well and
um i i i was really intrigued with the
idea um
of of bitcoin uh and and what it does
and what it could do and um you know
especially
for the future i think um i've always
kind of been an optimist and okay um
have always looked for ways to
um you know
i guess be most efficient with my time
and my energy and what i put into things
and um
yeah and i've always been curious about
investing and having um my money grow
and
um i guess back in 2015 2016 when i
first heard about bitcoin
that was intriguing to me
um and then um you know uh i kind of
went solely into that i guess about
2018. so
um
yeah and and then i i think like so many
other people it kind of drags you into
um this rabbit hole of of more
information um and kind of unites
many different
modalities like philosophy and economics
and history and
um so many of those things and
and you realize over time that
i think the root of many of our of our
issues
has always been the manipulation of
money and fiat currencies and
um
i i think
i i i don't know if everything can be
solved by that but i do think that uh
much of the world's plight is is
i guess revolving around that issue um
you know so yeah
but help me here because i know and i
can just tell from your answer that it's
so much more about money right like you
mentioned philosophy um and i want to go
deeper into this and i want to
understand the connection between
um
you know being sovereign over your
assets um
and fighting right and
my my like two cents or two satoshis if
you like is you know when you get in the
ring you have to take personal
responsibility right like you gotta
train otherwise you're getting
absolutely destroyed i don't know if
there's a connection there what do you
think
no question about it i think that's spot
on um you realize that you are
responsible for you um
in a lot of ways and the truth will
reveal itself in combat um
and there is no hiding for the most part
uh in the cage or in the ring um
and
you know the work that you put in um you
know especially over time is the work
that you get is what you're gonna get
out of it and
um i think that um
there's a lot to that and having that
person responsibility
um i think is huge for a lot of fighters
and
um you know i think
believing in yourself and having that
faith in yourself and believing in
um hard work and try not to let anybody
take that away from you
i think is important and i think over
time
um you know
you start to realize the value of
freedom and your ability to do things
that you do and the things that you gain
and the things that you literally fight
for
that you become
um very protective of that and very
protective of your time
uh
and what you spend um your energy on
yeah so you in order to survive in this
career you had to take personal
responsibility you had to
um you know work extremely hard and i
guess like you said it's you don't want
that taken away from you um and so
politically i'm always sort of finding
that fighters tend to fall on one side
of the spectrum
so
why
so so what happened when you started to
be orange pilled um did you share this
conversation with other fighters and do
you think they tend to have a similar
opinion
yeah i i don't think all fighters share
the same opinion but i do think the
majority of fighters do um i definitely
agree with you that i agree with you on
that um i have had uh many conversations
with with various fighters um
on on bitcoin uh and
you know ex i guess doing my best to
explain how i see things um and what is
going on and um i i think they start to
see the same things and
um
yeah they eventually kind of fall down
that rabbit hole as well um
so yeah i think that um you know
understanding that valuing your time
and um you know having that personal
personal responsibility uh has a lot to
do with a lot of people in the mixed
martial arts space getting into
you know bitcoin and i guess other
cryptos as well
i mean speaking about the cryptos when i
was preparing the show i was like damn
this guy's a bitcoin maxi i didn't
realize
how
hard on bitcoin you are so how did you
come to the realization that bitcoin was
the main currency for you and am i
correct you're a bitcoin maxi right
yeah i would say so um i think that uh
you know i am the kind of person that uh
like a lot of people i guess i i learn
best by making a lot of stupid mistakes
i guess and and so i think that
i i i am open-minded and at times that
can be
um a strength it can also be a weakness
at times um and i've experimented with
other cryptocurrencies
um but and and sometimes you hear the
thing of like
okay well this is decentralized and this
is a little bit more centralized but not
as much but it's got technology that's a
little bit more modern a little bit more
advanced and it could do this and that
but what i find is that um you know from
investing in some other cryptocurrencies
what i find is that um they also come to
the same
um i guess single points of failure and
all succumb to
uh manipulation or um i guess overall
[ __ ] if you will
um you know of just different things
happening whether it's um
you know
the majority of investors you know
getting in before everyone else does and
you know pre you know pre-mining or
um you know just
kind of taking their money out and then
leaving everyone else you know to hold
their bags and everyone getting screwed
so i've been through a few of those um
and not that i invested a ton of money
in it um but
when i did trade some bitcoin for those
things i was like man if i just held
bitcoin i would have been fine and then
i guess as i do more research into it or
as i did more research into it
um i started realizing of you
know there's just so many
um less vulnerabilities with bitcoin
than than some of the other um coins so
as i you know realized that over time i
i just
transitioned and sold everything else
that i had and put it all into bitcoin
like i said around 2018 uh and have just
i've just noticed that i'm just a lot
more
um calm and not trying to
you know uh let
you know try try to you know score a a
um you know this big
gain with a certain cryptocurrency or
whatever i'm not so stressed i'm just
kind of being like this is the thing
there's a reason why
um you know that they have the highest
market cap there's a reason why
um it has less vulnerabilities so it's
just has kind of given me more
confidence over time um having seen the
ups and downs everywhere and having seen
how bitcoin has has improved and
increased um
and become more popular overall
especially amongst
large uh financial institutions uh it's
given me more and more confidence that
that's the way to go
yeah i mean i think uh
one cycle will do that to you right like
2018 to get to become a bitcoin maxi
sounds about right i think a lot of
bitcoin maxies are being created right
now um but you you mentioned philosophy
so i want to get into that i really want
to understand you know because some
people just look at bitcoin as um you
know great technology some people look
at it as hedge against inflation others
look at it as just you know gains or
whatever um but for you it's
philosophical what does that mean
oh geez i mean um i think there's a lot
to it but
i guess
the idea that um
no one gets the opportunity to
uh mess with um
the currency no one gets to really mess
with the value it's a true
free market and it's the free market
really playing itself out um
and
i i think that um you know
if you are in charge of
the money if you are in charge of the
currency
um it a lot of times the
i guess the
things like greed is going to take over
or things like opportunity is going to
take over
and um i've found that
when you have a certain group of people
that is managing
things like that um
it's just it becomes
way too difficult for them to keep their
hands out of the cookie jar um
and
you know it's it's happened throughout
time and you look at the history of fiat
currencies i mean there's hundreds and
hundreds of fiat currencies that have
failed um and there's like a legit you
know certain time of that like
i think the average time is like 95
years or something like that but most of
them are in and out within like 25 years
my parents actually come from
south america they were both born in
peru
um and i i know in my lifetime they've
gone through i think two or three
different currencies and i remember them
talking about
um that and how you know the dollar was
so much stronger over there as a kid and
you know um so that was always kind of
fascinating to me but um
i think there is this um
beautiful
open network called the bitcoin network
that allows for everyone and anyone all
over the world to be a part of it um
and
for me
um
one thing that i've always tried to do
which is an important part of my ethos i
guess is just evolving uh i am you know
constantly trying to become
a better martial artist a better person
a better dad and all those things and
um you know
um
i i feel like um it is a natural part of
of evolution is to find a money that
can't be messed with and i feel like um
bitcoin is our
kind of best hope of that um and you
know everything from game theory to
um
you know
peace to
um
you know uniting everybody uh under one
kind of methodology that is actually
fair um i i think was was very
intriguing to me
yeah and i think you know speaking of
uniting what i tend to find and what i
personally love is how bitcoiners tend
to see the world in a certain way which
is a more logical realistic and truthful
reality um so something which i see
you're quite vocal on um is
just the world right now um in terms of
um the incorrect information that's
pushed down our throats um you know we
were told that inflation is transitory
um we've seen them try and say that
inflation is good because of higher
wages i think i saw something about it's
inflation is good because it's better
for the environment i don't know what
rubbish i read but i'm curious given
that our leaders are supposed to be
experts in the fields that they operate
why do you think
we are receiving so much false
information right now
um again i think a lot of it is
motivated by two things money and power
and um i think it is to their benefit um
to
give people certain information um or uh
suppress certain information i mean
again i i don't think it's any
coincidence that in um in the united
states uh specifically i would imagine
worldwide that uh we are not taught
truly um
how how the fiat system actually works
um yeah and that that information which
is suppressed um
you know keeps a lot of people down uh
in the dark and um i think everything in
general is an information game those
that are privy to the information those
that have the right information will
succeed those that do not um it
not saying that they will fail but it's
gonna be more difficult for them to
succeed um and
uh it's it's become this uh game of
information uh suppressing information
disinformation and saying what is
politically
i guess favorable to them um and whether
it's a politician or any kind of leader
in whatever space or people that are
benefiting from the system
of course they're going to
you know fight something that threatens
their way of life it's this is human
nature in general uh and when you begin
to see these lies pile up and you get
and you get a chance to see the other
side of it or you get to see you know
behind the curtain
which you haven't had access to and then
all of a sudden you see it and you see
more evidence of it um then uh you
realize that
this is a game that has been played for
a very long time whether you're talking
about
um you know the religious institutions
that have had power the religious
institutions that have had power um you
know
monarchies whatever it is um you know
from all over the world um it's
there is this struggle um to gain power
and keep power and
um
yeah that that's kind of been
something that has been quite
enlightening to me i guess
was that something that you discovered
through bitcoin or you or you sort of
felt before bitcoin
um i definitely felt it before bitcoin
uh just
i don't know you look at any space in a
field of
so-called experts um let's take the
mixed martial arts space for example
and i'm listening to
so-called experts talk about it or a
journalist talk about mixed martial arts
and they're saying a certain thing which
i know is absolutely false or inaccurate
um you know i i just like this that's
not how it is that's not how the game is
and if these people are are saying these
things either they're ignorant they're
spreading information uh purposely um to
throw people off or they're just not
very good at their jobs and i think it's
a combination of all three
uh
and
yeah so i mean if it's happening in that
space and then of course it's happening
all over the world like
i don't believe there are
many true experts in
different fields i i just don't i don't
buy it i i think that there's a lot of
incompetent people
everywhere and a lot of people do what
is necessary to do their job and just
that
and then there's a lot of people who
don't even do that i mean how many
people are just sitting there miserable
at their jobs and
um are putting in minimal effort and you
know getting through their nine to five
uh so
you start looking at other aspects of it
and other areas of expertise and you
know you start to realize well this is
happening everywhere and
um i don't know and i mean again how
many times have we seen
just blatantly false uh information
about bitcoin uh and these are like the
biggest publications in the world and
you start realizing we're being lied to
or
again people just aren't very good at
their jobs
so the thing is i think i would say that
more people are waking up to this
realization that we're being lied to and
particularly the whole men can get
pregnant thing like that that's just
this weird thing that's like popped up
in the last few weeks um
but
my question is so it's 2022 and we can
have these conversations and i don't
think we'd be called conspiracy
theorists but if we had it maybe like
two years ago people would call us
conspiracy theorists so i'm interested
do you think
that like elites world leaders the davos
people because davos is going on right
now um do you think they overplayed
their hand to some extent over the last
two three years and now you know people
are waking up
i think
yeah to a certain extent and i still
think people are
are still asleep um and not saying i
think a lot of people are awakening are
waking up to it
uh but when you see such compliance
globally uh with certain things that are
in play and
i i think they became more emboldened by
it and kind of are saying what a lot of
the conspiracy theorists were kind of
thinking um and also framing it in
different ways and being very subtle in
in how they uh explain what they're
doing um a lot of this is about control
um you know uh for those that have ever
you know lived in a community which has
this hoa
which which kind of are these board
members in the community that manage the
neighborhood
um
there's there's a lot of tricky things
that going on that go on there and again
not necessarily malicious but um
humans in general aren't great at
managing things and when you talk about
things like the economy or
you know um the government in general in
these massive countries with complicated
infrastructure and all these things up
like you're not going to get it
right and also like
as far as
you know if we had 10 people and we all
asked them what would be the best way to
manage
you know let's say a town a city a state
a country
um
it's going to be a debate over control
how do we control or allow for the
citizenry to operate
and there's varying
approaches and theories on that
and for many people
they like nodding their head and saying
yes and
i trust whatever the government they
have our best interests and i'm gonna do
whatever they say and
um i think there's a lot of danger in
that um and uh
you know i think we we forget especially
in this country that um the freedoms
that uh we fought for and the freedoms
that built this country and the idea of
the united states is what makes us
um powerful and i think we're giving
away a lot of those liberties um
willingly um not knowing uh and not
thinking about the long term
you mentioned um before
the church you know monarchies these
traditional institutions from you know
way back when when you know they would
control pretty much everything
um
i've spoken to a few people um and they
sort of talk about us reaching peak
centralization in 2025 and we do in fact
eventually move on to this bitcoin
standard um meaning this decentralized
standard essentially um so we've seen
the power dynamics change we've seen the
power hierarchies change do you think
the way the world is now and the you
know the supposed democracy that we have
all these these two to the two system
parties um do you think that's gonna
change and we actually will move to a
decentralized
standard oh geez i i don't know i i fear
what happens if we go too far the other
way i mean
if too much centralization happens can
we go back the other way that that i
think is the question um especially in
regards to
um
whether it's military control or
um
you know that whoever is in control with
governmental or otherwise uh in their
ability to uh invade our privacies and
and how we operate and where we're going
and how we do things um
i i i fear for that and like you said a
lot of that is being masked by
um
you know doing things what's good for
the environment and what's hilarious and
and i'm not the first to point this out
of course but it's like all these people
that are flying into
you know the world economic forum uh
conferences on their private jets and
you know getting picked up and and their
huge rolls royces or whatever and you
know having the biggest homes in the
world and having you know 40 cars or
whatever are the people that are telling
us how we should be
um living our lives to lessen the impact
on the environment i think what's really
going on
uh is that i think they view it as a
population issue now why is it a
population issue is because
um the more that uh and this is you know
my opinion i guess that
if there is a larger middle class
amongst
this large population of let's say 8
billion people
um that means that those people are
going to be consuming more resources and
if they're consuming
more resources that means that there's
less resources for those people at the
top
so if we can lessen population um or
keep people uh at
an economic disadvantage that means that
they they don't eat up the resources
that i
you know get to value at the top um i
could keep everything for myself um
and battle it out with you know uh my
other wealthy friends so i
i think that's kind of what's going on
and we're seeing that kind of play out
already with with supply chains and
energy issues and all that stuff and i
think that's really what it's about it's
um i want these resources for me
uh and uh and i think that's kind of
where this economic disempowerment is
coming from um whether it's you know
false narratives or disinformation uh
and things like that
the reality is that every
energy source or any type of energy
production has its advantages and
disadvantages no matter uh whether it's
green energy or
you know uh oil or whatever it is
um it is what it is and there's no
easy solution uh with with with any of
them um so i i i don't buy that
narrative i think it's uh
i i don't know anyways that's that those
are my thoughts on that
no i i agree with you you're so awake i
love it um i i just with everything
that's going on in the world right now i
find it so hard to have conversations
with people that just don't see what i
see um like i was at a gathering just a
few weeks ago and
i i was having a conversation with this
guy and
obviously it got political because
politics just runs through my veins um
and i'd said to him i was like yeah i
mean you have a president that like
can't even string a full sentence
together and he was like that's a
conspiracy i'm like what do you mean
i was like what do you mean i don't know
i'm not i was like he can't i've seen
the videos and he's like that's a
conspiracy
and i'm like what do you mean like how
is like okay they complain about the
environment right and then you've got
them all flying in on private jets
surely if they've really cared about the
environment they would have hopped on
economy together you know on like
american airlines i don't know if you're
coming in from europe get on ryanair
easyjet but they don't do it
yeah
so why are people so asleep
yeah i don't know
again it's um
again
any the problem is is that like
you can justify a lot of different
narratives and you can argue in a lot of
different ways and the key is you know
and this is a very common saying don't
uh
don't listen to what they say watch what
they do
and and i think that's the key and
people who are
on the inside and and see these things
really playing out uh know what the deal
is and um
people just aren't being very honest
about it
well here's something more positive um
elon musk is speaking out about it um
jeff bezos is trying to be elon musk i
think he's now sort of like talking
about inflation he's sort of you know
calling out all this bs um which is
fascinating because before you know your
conspiracy theorist and you're you're
you're de-platformed and everything um
so do you think more major influential
businessmen ceos are going to start
speaking out about this even celebrities
remember kanye west was probably a bit
too early to speak out about it um
so do you think more will and then maybe
that might wake up more of the
population
i think so and i hope so i i think that
um
at the end of the day what people need
to realize no matter what kind of
position or what kind of
uh power you have um is that uh
eventually they will come for you
yeah no matter what you say or or what
you do um and if you are just sitting
there and being controlled by a certain
narrative or afraid to speak your mind
then this is what people in positions of
power want um and people need to realize
we don't live in china we live we live
in the united states and freedom of
speech and our ability to say what's on
our mind is one of the most important
things that we have as a country if that
fails everything else falls apart after
that
and you know i i could even you know
speak for myself you know i i have a job
i'm in media um you know not that i have
this you know burning desires to say all
these different things to all these
different people but you know you do
feel a little bit limited at times right
um
but i think when you're a jeff bezos or
or elon musk and you're like wait a sec
i am one of the richest and most
powerful people in the world maybe i
should be saying what's on my mind
maybe the media is going to say bad
things about me regardless and uh it's
on me to just
you know speak my mind and and fight
back to what's going on here um
and if you don't you're a major part of
the problem especially if you have the
power to be able to change things um and
influence things um not everyone is is
uh influencing things in a positive
direction or um you know for the
majority of people um but i i think that
people are catching on and starting to
see
that um
you know this uh this curtain is
starting to come down and and things are
being revealed
yeah i think so and that's one of the
things that i love about crypto and i
also think um
it's part of the reason why they're so
anti-bitcoin is just because of the
because we've created this community and
safe haven safe space i hate that term
um but to talk about these things um and
i actually did a podcast yesterday and
somebody um they were london people um
and they were really surprised at how
blunt
and to the point i was and they you know
they just weren't used to it in the uk
they were just like oh my god like if we
said that we'd lose our jobs and so i
find so much peace and like
kind of reassurance
in this community because you can say
these things
yeah i think one of the things that is
being lost um
majorly especially when it comes to
education and
just the overall narrative is
independent thinking is completely being
lost and and i guess to go back to your
first question
i think that's another thing in regards
to fighters is that you must think
independently if you just follow what is
taught to you then
you are more liable to repeat mistakes
and get caught in the cage
with those things you have to be able to
think outside the box and be creative
and go
what is going to truly give me the best
results not for
joe or rick or sarah or whatever what is
going to give me the best results for my
performance in this fight against this
person
so you have to be willing to
um i guess be
be combative in a variety of ways and
how you see things and how you train and
how you approach things um because you
ultimately are the one that's going to
either succeed or fail um so yes you
have a team around you and you hope that
you have the best people around you but
the individual fighter uh you know ends
up taking the responsibility um you know
really at the end of the day and
you have to be able to think
independently
uh you know to try to find the best
result possible and i think that is
something that is is being lost today
for sure in the education system and uh
and otherwise so um
i hope that this spurs a new
um
you know i guess
um
age of independent thinking uh
especially in a world where there's so
much information you have to be able to
comb through it and find out what what
really is the truth and um it's not
always so clear you're gonna have to do
the work and investigate for yourself
truly um not just follow a conspiracy
theory or follow what the media is is is
saying sometimes it's somewhere in the
middle or maybe somewhere where it's not
even
out there you have to just go out and
find and really think for yourself on
you know logically of what what is it
going on what is making sense and to be
able to connect the dots in in an
intelligent way
i think you make a really important
point because i actually um think that
life
is
the ring
like i think life is the jungle
and i think people
don't realize how
i don't know if this is a british term
but doggy dog we say i don't know if
that's you know is that okay i don't
know yeah yeah how how doggy dog it is
and just how rough it is um and that's
why you have so many soft pe soft and
entitled individuals because they think
that they're entitled to an easy life
they think they're entitled to all these
things um and you know you're in the
ring and you know you're are you
entitled to to that belt no are you
entitled to the money no you have to
work for it and i think
that is why physical challenge
is so important
um in creating a better society
no question about it i think it um it
it identifies a more accurate picture of
where you fit into the world
but also you realize that everything is
struggle i mean if you want to succeed
in anything
you have to know what failure is like
and you have to know what it's like to
come back from failure and you have to
be able to pick yourself up uh and also
as you succeed as you start climbing
that ladder remember what it was like to
be in that position and to constantly
understand that we live in an evolving
world that is surrounded by chaos and
it's up to us to be able to interpret
that chaos uh evolve and adapt you know
we we've lived for we've lived very well
for a long time especially here in the
united states where anytime i go to the
supermarket i can get eggs i can get
milk i can get chicken i can get
whatever the heck i want
i can go to my fancy supermarkets well
what's happening now is that those
things aren't available anymore you know
some of those things anyway or
the majority of those things are
becoming more and more expensive now i'm
in a position where it's not so much of
a big deal for for for someone like me
thankfully but for a lot of people that
are on a very strict budget with large
families or whatever it is
what happens when milk isn't readily
available what happens when um eggs
aren't readily available
water you know simple things that we
take for granted um you know energy
sources all these things the people are
going to revolt and it's not going to be
pretty uh those that are weak will be
left behind um those that are stronger
you know
physically economically whatever it is
um will probably succeed so it is i i
agree with you i i think that um you
know it we
all the way from like the most basic
form of uh the most basic life forms all
the way to the most complicated ones
there's a battle going on all the time
um and a lot of it is a battle for
resources and you know the most
intelligent and well positioned
creatures will succeed
how do you position yourself that's the
question
well how do you position yourself
i think that's what it comes down to
right it's like well
when when things get crazy and when the
money is being manipulated
um
what will remain i i do think that um
you know game theory and
um a lot of other things uh efficiency
speed
uh ease of of maneuvering i think
bitcoin is that answer that people will
have to transition to now do you want to
have to make that choice or do you want
to um be positioned before you have to
make that choice and i think that's what
it comes down to
but
i do think things like the lightning
network is uh one of those uh things
that has
really taken things to to a whole new
level uh to ultimately lead bitcoin down
that uh media exchange medium of
exchange route um
you know i i think bitcoin is one of
those things that if you have money
saved uh and you wanted to store it
indefinitely forever um that was the
answer
but as far as medium of exchange i think
like the lightning network has taken
things to a whole new level um which is
very exciting it's still very early um
but um
i i that's what i think uh bitcoin is is
about is now it's extremely volatile and
people always point to that
but um you know what happens when you
have no other place to go what happens
when you can't park your money anywhere
else what happens when financial
institutions governments realize that uh
they're in a losing game uh and they
have nowhere to go um
it's
it's going to be interesting
so we
have this civil war coming um we've got
the middle class dying out um it's all
pretty terrible
um so how where do you see bitcoin then
in like 10 years from now you know you
mentioned medium of exchange um do you
actually think we're gonna get onto a
bitcoin standard like do you think this
is what i think just honest just to make
my question a bit clearer i feel like
all of us who are orange peeled or red
pilled or whatever it is are gonna just
form this society somewhere whether you
know whether texas breaks off i don't
know i don't think that's to happen
whether it's latin america i don't know
i think geographically we're all going
to be we're going to move together and
live in this kind of like
parallel alternative society
what do you think
it's quite possible i mean i think
that's kind of
happening with with the current wealthy
right and i think that
every generation kind of experiences
that whether it's
a tech boom or the oil barons of the
past or you know the big industrial
complexes that have been formed uh
throughout you know the ages i think
that um
there's another one that's going to come
and um is that going to be bitcoin i
think so
um but um
i don't know you know obviously it
remains to be seen
um
but
when you look at what's happening and
you look at you know the fact that there
aren't many answers to
many of the issues that are going on
i think bitcoin satisfies a lot of those
needs and
you know there's a lot of governments
that are experiencing a lot of issues
everywhere
and the united states isn't uh as
powerful as it used to be
and if you look at
you know
the ideals the american ideals and the
philosophies
uh and the men that helped
you know to [ __ ] to find this country
and develop you know the constitution
all those things i mean what's more
american than bitcoin and um it comes
down to
uh do you want to lead or do you want to
have to follow
and when you're talking about a finite
resource or finite
set of assets
it's it's going to be yet another battle
for those for those resources for those
assets which i think bitcoin will be
um and you look at where we're heading
everything is turning more digital uh
and
i i think it simplifies things in a lot
of different ways uh so i'm i'm real i'm
real curious to see what that timeline
is is it five years is it 10 years is it
20 is it 30 i don't know
but i think that when it happens it's
going to be
uh very very quickly as they say
gradually gradually then suddenly so um
i i think that's that's the way it is
and it's like
you know adoption uh begets adoption and
it spreads out you know kind of far and
wide but then all of a sudden it's just
going to be um this tunnel and this
massive um accumulation of of resources
very quickly uh in order to save
themselves
now i totally agree with you and i think
it's going to be so interesting to see
how it all plays out um but i want to
talk a little bit about fighting um
because that's sort of what you're well
that is what you're known for from from
uh from before all of this um so let's
get into it you've been in multiple main
event title fights um with many other
big names like jose aldo and bj penn so
i always ask um fighters what goes
through your mind being the last walk
out for a title fight um you know you're
the last one there how do you handle
that kind of pressure and you got the
music going and it's just a lot isn't it
it is i think that um
the biggest thing and i don't think i
really
was aware of it in the moment but it's
such a simple answer and it feels like
i'm you know choosing uh
you know the easiest thing to say but it
really is very true
it's uh really connecting to your breath
if you're not very connected to yourself
um and if you're not breathing properly
i think that you're not going to be very
present and when you're not very present
you're not focused on the task at hand
and you start looking at what's on the
periphery like things like
the fans the fact that you are the last
fight the fact that it's for the world
championship belt the fact that there's
so much money on the line there's so
much pressure on the line your friends
family
people are watching all over the world
and you know i'm nervous
being afraid to fail all those things
which really don't serve you in the
moment um
and and the reality is is that you know
for for me i i put in so many hours of
um
you know love and passion and sweat
blood and tears literally into my craft
that
it's just another day of me trying to
perform
those skills that i've accumulated over
the years
but
it's hard to stay focused on that task
especially you know doing the interviews
all week and the press conferences and
everyone asking the same questions and
you start to think like the other people
on the outside
and that is something that i think i
really didn't understand so well as a
fighter as a professional athlete um and
you know it's like you know okay just
stay present all right that's fine how
do i do that um and i think it's staying
as calm as possible how do you stay calm
breathing connecting to yourself um you
know taking yourself out of the picture
if you need to isolate yourself so i
would i would try to do those things but
i don't i'm not sure i understood the
importance of
um breath and meditation and how to stay
as present as possible and um those are
things that i'm still
learning and trying to understand uh to
this very day so i think i'm probably
way more positioned to compete better at
uh i'm gonna be 47 in a couple days uh
at this age but my body is broken down
you know when i was young and you know
uh you know full of energy and ready to
go i i didn't have that uh ability to
always get centered i'd have amazing
performances and i'd be like how did i
was like in the flow how did i do that
how did that happen it's because i
wasn't trying i was just
you know staying present and
not understanding that process um
you know and still trying to understand
that process um is is a fascinating
thing
yeah i mean ultimately you know it's a
performance um and like when before i
perform if i'm like going on the news or
whatever like all those like negative
like thoughts come to my head and i have
to like breathe it out so like
how do you how do you i know you talk
about breath but like can we go into
this a little bit more how do you remove
the negative thoughts you know and
because it's a lot
yeah i know for sure the the mind is
really um it's such an amazing thing
right um but i don't think it has it
plays a great part in performance to be
honest i think that um how we're able to
clean and wipe
that mind clean
uh and start from a new i think is the
key that's when we're truly alive and
aware
and i think i have the the wonderful
honor and opportunity of seeing that
play out uh with my kids like
forgetting that uh a tree or
great weather or grass or something as
as simple as that that we take for
granted
of how amazing that is and
um our mind will either uh make
something a bigger deal or not or um you
know you'll kind of look past certain
things and you won't appreciate certain
things in the moment i think one of the
easier ways to kind of talk about
something like that as far as
performance is
i guess walking
i guess a tight wire or a rope a tight
rope um
if that thing is one foot off the ground
we could probably cross that tightrope
like it's not a big deal why because our
mind is visualizing it's like okay
that's only a foot off the ground if we
fall it's not a big deal and you'll go
and do that 30 times and you'll be
totally fine whereas we'll take that
exact same tightrope and we'll put it
between two buildings you know at the
top of new york city and all of a sudden
it's a very different thing now it is
because if we make that mistake right
we're screwed
but
did it really change it really didn't
but our mind sees it as so much
different and now we're sweating and you
know we're
we're seeing it as this completely
different thing so i think our ability
to calm down and um
you know i guess
take things from the periphery and be
able to shut it out or bring things in
to focus on it's how we're able to focus
on the important things or what we
should be focusing on and also be able
to kind of delete and uh take away the
things that don't serve us
and i guess
being able to
siphon through those things and figure
out what those things are uh it can be
uh i guess not not to use a pun but a
balancing act right
no i like the punish kid
perception really is reality um you're
totally right it's why um they always
say the cliche like imagine the audience
in their underwear or something like
that you know so the pressure's off it
you know it's not so important anymore
you know you're not you're not gonna
fall between the two buildings um the
pressure's off um but it's actually
interesting because um i i i sort of
follow ufc while i did more when i was
younger and because my brother was
really really into it um but there's a
lot of fighters and competitors um of
the usc that claim the promotion has a
monopoly on mma um we've also seen um
gsp become very influential in creating
a union for fighters so i want to know
if you think the fc has this anti-trust
issue and are you pro the union the
unionization of sport
yeah i think that uh
whether the ufc has a monopoly or not um
i think you know certainly there's a lot
of other organizations that you can
point to like the pfl bellator uh you
know one fc
uh that have um you know
a great organization with that gives
fighters options i think where the
problem lies
is are the claims that fighters are
independent contractors
so
when let's say an organization like the
ufc hires a so-called independent
contractor
they sign them to let's say three fights
six fights eight fights 12 fights
they're an independent contractor but
they can't fight for anyone else yeah so
that's where i think the issues lie
um and i know you know that the ufc has
had some issues i guess with some of
their contracts and whether those were
legally valid or fair um and that's kind
of where their issues um
have been in the past so
i i don't know as far as uh unionization
or uh power to the fighters absolutely i
think that uh fighters should have way
more power there should be more
bargaining power for them they should
have the ability to
um especially if they're in those main
events uh to get more money and get more
power um as far as negotiation how much
they can make you know obviously francis
delgado who is a bitcoiner as well is
kind of involved in that uh sort of
drama right now uh so i wish him the
best i hope he's able to do it but
it becomes difficult for fighters to
unionize
i guess especially if um
there are certain fighters that are
going to be in more main events than say
someone who's on the lower tier so i
guess what what needs to happen is
the fighters do need to come together
and they need to figure out uh what
determines the pay
for certain fighters and i think that's
it's going to take time um and that
needs to be hashed out um but um
some some kind of
uh determination of what fighters should
be paid based on experience
uh
what what you know where they lie on the
main card is it a main event is it a
non-main event are they a prelim uh is
this for a top 10 ranking is it for a
top 20 ranking a top 50 ranking is it
unranked fighters is this your first
fight is it debut so there's a lot of
different tiers which i think the
fighters uh kind of fall into and
finding out what that pay is for that uh
level um i think is the tricky thing um
i i hope they're they're able to figure
out over time
but certainly you know an organization
like the ufc is very powerful and and
you know they have the means
uh you know legally
and economically uh to be very dominant
over the fighters who have yet to really
come together so i i hope some kind of
uh resolution uh is able to
uh transpire i guess in the next well in
the near future anyway
the reason i ask is because obviously
you're a bitcoin maxim we all know um
you know what bitcoin stands for its
philosophy in terms of um free
enterprise free enterprise and
capitalism um
so do you feel
i know you you know you want to have
more power to the fighters but do you
feel this sort of goes against the free
market in capitalism
yeah i mean that's the thing it's it's a
tricky one you know because i also think
that um the fighters do determine that
um
i think that uh here's where it gets
tricky is that
um the fighters need to
uh fight for their value right you have
the guys like conor mcgregor who has you
know uh because of his performances and
because of his name and notoriety over
time has uh demanded um you know tens of
millions of dollars uh to go out there
and perform um and he's got the numbers
to back it up
um
and you know those pay-per-view numbers
uh you know at the end kind of determine
his value um and the ufc determines his
value based on the numbers that he
brings in for for the company
um but i think that when you let's say
compare it to
other
um
you know
i guess leagues like the nfl or nba or
whatever uh and you look at what the ufc
fighters are being paid
and how much how much the organization
is being how much that how much is being
brought in by the organization
um you know it's not it's not on the
same
uh level as say the nfl so
i don't know i mean i don't have enough
of uh the the economic knowledge
of the different the various leagues uh
you know specifically of what is being
brought in and what is being paid out to
the fighters but i do think there's a
large discrepancy um and i think it's up
to the fighters to either come together
or not or
um you know don't complain and go out
there and do their best to
um win the fights that they need to win
and and go from there um but uh it is
tricky and like you said i i think that
um
you know with with the free market um
i i think the options um
[Music]
can be somewhat limited you know the ufc
is certainly um a leader in mixed
martial arts and you have the best
opportunity to make money in the ufc
um
but and and it's still new so i think
there's a lot to be worked out and um
yeah it's just a different environment
also than when i was fighting certainly
in what way
um
well you know i i guess
people might call me one of the early
pioneers but there was ufc fighters way
before me you know starting in 1993 um i
was in the ufc in like 2005.
so uh certainly the economics have
changed significantly i think there was
like
the ufc was purchased in
i guess the late 90s or early 2000s for
like a couple million dollars two
million dollars they're now they were
purchased
um what five years ago uh by wwme for
4.2 or 4.4 billion dollars
so um
just that alone kind of shows you how
far we've gone um as far as you know the
business and what they're able to bring
in um
so kenny what are you working on now um
you know what what are you doing um i
know you have a podcast and what's going
on with you personally
yeah um thanks yeah so i have podcast uh
john anik who's uh the the play by play
commentator for the ufc uh we have a
podcast together called the aniket
flooring podcast where we recap um you
know mixed martial arts news and fights
that are happening uh throughout the
week
um and
i
am doing um color commentary for the pfl
uh they do shows on espn
um and right now we're
we have our
uh regular season uh
coming up we have one more uh we have
three more events coming up for the
regular season before we uh get into the
postseason uh and then i'm doing
commentary for a show called battlebots
on discovery channel uh which has been a
lot of fun and uh and then i got uh
i have a um
jiu jitsu instructional uh at
kennyflooringmartialarts.com for those
that are interested in in martial arts
and and jiu jitsu and uh taking their
game uh uh up a notch and uh
that's pretty much it just staying busy
and uh yeah trying trying to try to do
what i love
good and um where can people follow you
um i know you mentioned the jiu jitsu
but where else can people follow you get
in touch with you keep up with
everything that you're doing
yeah if they want to um you know follow
me i'm at kenny florian uh at k-e-n-n-y
f-l-o-r-i-a-n
uh on social media that's uh on twitter
and instagram and uh yeah hit me up
kenny i wanna thank you so much it's
been such a pleasure having you on um
you know these conversations are so hard
to have sometimes um and it's just so
refreshing and just such a pleasure to
speak with like-minded people so thank
you so much for coming on uh pleasure
was mine thank you so much
thanks kenny and guys thank you so much
for watching don't forget to tune in
next week and hit the subscribe button
so you never miss a video we'll see you
next week bye bye say ohio pancho
you